at this moment rockets can be heard as
the conflict in
israel is going from bad to worse israel
planning for an error and
ground offensive you're hearing the
sirens and the announcements
behind foreign correspondent trey yingst
following the breaking developments
joins us live from southern
israel now good evening trey what's
happening
good evening just a few minutes ago
israel announced that it was launching
both
ground and air strikes into the gaza
strip
we just saw factions inside gaza start
responding with rocket fire into
southern israel
you can hear the warning going off right
now telling people to head for bomb
shelters
we're seeing a lot of movement on the
gaza strip right now my cameraman come
here look off in the distance here
a lot of interception rounds going off
there israel's missile defense system
working overtime tonight trying to take
some of this rocket fire
that's headed in right now a senior
hamas official speaking to fox news
confirmed that 103 palestinians inside
gaza have died so far
since this offensive began of them our
children
on monday night after hamas the rule of
towards jerusalem today though some
operations wanted to launch against
israel
we know seven ant were taken out by the
israeli defense force
this came as rocket barrages were
continuing throughout the day
and even once today the city of a lot
which is a city
more than a hundred and fifty miles from
where we are right now
it fire position we're standing in now
is in a
door it's very close to the israeli
order and
we actually visited one of the artillery
units where they were firing
the gaza strip clearly tonight israeli
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
looking to ratchet
[Music]
tons of incoming rocket fire right now
from the gaza strip
one just landed right next to our hotel
and you can see that the iron dome is
able to intercept some of them
but others are flying right by we've
seen barrage after barrage tonight
as the faction's inside gaza and you can
see an interception round flying there
and an explosion
where to get down here
[Music]
we do know the israeli defense forces
have called up 9
000 reserve troops they are concerned
that moving forward
they're going to need the extra help as
they prepare for the possibility of a
full-scale
ground invasion into the gaza strip off
behind me right now you can hear israeli
fighter jets
hitting a number of targets throughout
gaza brett trey yanks live on the ground
as he has been from the very beginning
trey thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else